[Music]
but this alienation takes place solely
in language which here appears that its
characteristic significance in the world
of ethical order in law and command in
the actual world of counsel only
language has the essence for its content
it is the form of that content but here
it has for its content the form itself
the form which language itself is and is
authoritative as language it is the
power of speech as that which performs
what has to be performed for it is the
real existence of the pure self as self
in speech self consciousness qua
independent suffered individuality comes
as such into its existence so that it
exists for others otherwise the eye is
pure eye is non-existent it is not there
in every other expression it is immersed
in a reality and is in a shape from
which it can withdraw itself it is
reflected back into itself from its
action as well as from its physiognomic
expression and dissociates itself from
such an imperfect existence in which
there is always at once
too much as too little letting it remain
lifeless behind language under contains
it in its purity in it alone expresses
the eye and the eye itself this real
existence of the eye is quadrille
existence and objectivity which he has
in it the true nature of the eye the eye
is this particular eye but equally the
universal eye it's manifesting is also
at once the externalization and
vanishing of this particular eye and as
a result the eye remains in its
universality the eye that utters itself
is heard or perceived it is an
inflection in which it has immediately
passed into unity with those for whom it
is a real existence and is it universal
self consciousness then it is perceived
or heard means that its real existence
dies away this its other Ness has been
taken back into itself and its real
existence is just this that is a self
conscious now as a real
resistance it is not a real existence
and through this vanishing it is a real
existence this vanishing is thus itself
at once it's abiding it is its own
knowing of itself and it's knowing
itself as a self that has passed over
into another self that has been
perceived and is universal
paragraph 508 a very long paragraph lot
of stuff going on there is focused
primarily on this issue of language and
I think for those of you who are
interested in the philosophy of language
or linguistics or other allied fields
you may in fact be both very happy but
also rather frustrated with Hegel's
treatment here and I want to say a few
things about that before we actually
launch into the discussion of the text
one is that Hegel although he talks
quite a bit about language is not really
a philosopher of language as such he
views language as an important component
in how human beings interact with each
other in the world in fact it's an
inextricable as we're gonna see here you
cannot get away from it but that said
you you know you're not really seeing
him develop something that's exactly the
same as everybody else when they're
turning specifically to language Hegel
is interested in language primarily as a
medium not not just for its own sake we
might say as we saw the 20th century
both in analytic and continental
philosophy turning to language and
paying very close attention to it the
other thing I want to say is I think if
you're going to try to make sense of
this text and you're trying to make
sense of Hegel's views there's two
things you want to keep in mind first of
all remember that this discussion of
language is nested in this entire
dialectic that we're examining about
culture and alienation but specifically
here about the noble and base
consciousness and about wealth and state
power so we want to keep all of that in
mind as we're going through it don't
make too much of it the other is you're
probably going to be unsuccessful if
you're trying to map Hegel onto other
thinkers or you're trying to understand
Hegel in light of other philosophers of
language so you may want to hold off on
any sort of comparative or critical work
until you actually see what he is doing
here and just focus on that for its own
sake now all that said you notice that I
have a sort of triatic structure here
and it's definitely not the triad of
thesis antithesis synthesis so don't
read that in instead we have three
polarities here and there they're
brought together by language as Hegel is
going to talk about and there is an
alienation that has taken place in the
previous paragraphs that he refers to
that he begins this this paragraph by
talking about so the question is well
what is alienated from what and what how
is the alienation actually taking place
and then what do we learn by looking at
this and language is gonna turn out to
be at the very center of this so he says
this alienation that we are looking at
takes place solely in language in praha
right which here appears in its
characteristic significance now that's
kind of an understatement right language
doesn't appear in its characteristic
significance for Hegel much of the time
he he writes in language he works in
language but he doesn't FEMA ties it all
that often so he says what is the kind
of language that we're looking at here
and he makes a distinction he says in
the world of ethical order in law and
command and in the actual world in
Council only right so let's let's dwell
on that for a moment just before we go
into looking at what he's gonna say
about language and form and content so
in the universal ethical order what we
have is law and Hegel is rightly picking
out here that law is not just a matter
of thought not just a matter of a reason
not just a matter of sort of some sort
of instinct and planted into us but it
has a linguistic or expressive side to
it which means that it's going to be
connected with culture in general and
particular cultures within which human
beings live then we have command and
counsel what's the difference between
command and counsel well a command and
imperative says you must do this you
ought to do this council says this would
be a good idea for you to do
but what I'm saying doesn't have any
binding force on you so you you you may
give commands to yourself or other
people may give commands to you if
they're entitled to command you you may
give commands to others shine my shoes
you know you say that to the person who
is charged with with keeping your
clothes clean if you have any such
person right probably telling yourself
hey it's time to shine your shoes let's
get on with that right that's the way I
am counsel as well you know you'd be
prudent for you to do this but you don't
have to because it's up to you so you
see the difference between those and
these are all linguistic right you you
don't give commands to a person outside
of some language even when we're talking
about computers right you give the
command in a computer language and you
can say well that's just a bunch of you
know numeric or logical operations
arranged in certain ways sure but from
our perspective it's a language so these
are all linguistic now what does this
have to do with what's going on in this
this alienation of the individual from
the ethical order he says language in
these in law command and in a council
language has the essence for its content
right so Hegel is playing off of this
you know form and content distinction
you know language is a form right you
can you can express in a number of
different ways the same content and if
we use you know ferritin indicial sir
you know the great french linguist who
knew a lot of languages and by the way
suggested that if you want to be a
linguist you need to actually study
languages not just you know study a
language and then philosophize on that
basis but do some good comparative work
he says look you've got you know
something like a sign a word and then
there's something that it signifies
Hegel is operating with something like
this and mine here the sign would be or
the signifier would be the form and that
could be you know in French you know arm
could be an English tree could be in
German bomb could be whatever we want it
to be right and then there's the same
content
tree over there the thing that we knock
our hand against right and there's lots
of things that we can refer to like that
where we can say aha the book right we
get into the realm of metaphor and
analogy and metonymy when we say aha
Hegel right now it says Hegel's
phenomenology of spirit on the book but
Hegel himself is not contained in here
but we could say that Hegel's mind in a
certain way or Hegel's thoughts now it's
not Hegel's mind like everything that he
has in his brain at one single point in
time of course because it's it's this
long long discursive thing that takes a
very long path to true you know that we
have to traverse in order to understand
what he was saying and frankly I'm not
sure that we even totally understand
when we're done with it and there's a
whole conversation we had about that but
you notice we're doing that in language
he said well what is the form what is
the content and how does language hook
up with stuff like this and stuff like
this you know words are coming out of my
mouth going into this video camera
you're hearing it on your computer we
could say isn't that mysterious what the
hell is going on there how is meaning
being conveyed and again Hegel is not
going into some huge philosophy of
language or linguistics making sense of
all of that showing its anthropological
you know dimensions or the he's focused
here on a few things but he is saying
some things that are very profound and
very interesting
so he says language has the essence for
its content we saw that already at the
beginning in sense certainty where Hegel
is going to refer us back to a little
bit later in this paragraph isn't me in
sense certainty we found that language
allowed us to say things like here now
there then and then in the you know
further sections right the section on
perception right we found that that
language could be used to talk about the
thing and its properties and each one of
these words could be used to peg a sort
of essence that we could put there
in there and there and there and this
was a really fundamental metaphysical
issue that Hagel is dealing with now
we're interested in it primarily in
terms of social dynamics and meaning so
he goes on and he says here we go
language has the essence for its content
and is the form of that content that's
the interesting thing about language
language can be self referential it is
the form of that content right and then
he says here it has for its content the
form itself
there's recursive 'ti or reflexivity
here so language this is a very
important point language is part of what
allows spirit or you know being in and
for itself human being to have that
connection to itself to be able to in
this case he's very interested in this
name itself not name itself like me
saying Gregory Sadler right are you
naming me hey dr. Sadler you know or my
mom you know when I was little Gregory
Brian Sadler but my capacity to say I
and for you to understand this I over
here as not being the same I that you
say but in a certain way also being that
same I essentially were naming in
essence but we're also the content is
also becoming the form here so he goes
on and he says for the form which
language itself is and it's
authoritative as language and here he
talks about the power of speech and
Miller chooses a word here to translate
house food and house fruits right I was
good fear of morality actually I think
in the German text and as fruit he talks
in terms of performance and I like that
because in in you know 20th century
english-speaking philosophy of language
we make a distinction sometimes between
performative and other sorts of
statements so for example when I say
promise that I will XYZ that that I
promise is a performative I am thereby
making a promise by saying the words I
promise or when somebody excuse
I think it's Austin's example you know I
pronounce you husband and wife
the perdón I pronounce you husband and
wife the the minister or rabbi or you
know priest or whatever it is the
officiant who's who's doing that could
be Justice of the Peace is carrying
something I was doing something with
language is acting through language
here's what's really interesting Hegel
sees these sorts of things like law
command and counsel as themselves
performative they're not descriptive you
can't break a law down into simply a
description and we might say oh they're
really more imperative well it can be
imperative and performative at the same
time because these are not mutually
exclusive categories
so there's a lot interesting going on
here that that we we go just doesn't
really work with but I think that the
translation is particularly solicitous
at this point in in the word choice I
mean I was screwin literally mean sort
of look to lead out right to to work out
to bring out of something to to perform
right so he goes on and he says it's the
power of speech is that which performs
what has to be performed and then he
says it's the real existence of the pure
self as self so we don't have a pure
self on its own disengaged from the
world this is typical Hegel right we
don't have a pure self apart from its
its instantiation we don't have a pure
self apart from its action it has to be
made
actual real via click this is a constant
dynamic in Hegel and now language is
being picked out here as one mode of
that vehicle a kind of that actuality of
that gig and Stan Lika existence that
objective
right so he goes on and he says the real
existence of the pure self itself in
speech self-consciousness qua
independent separate individuality comes
into existence so that it exists for
others and this is a very interesting
thing to say right in speech in language
in in actually dis coursing back and
forth we are able to be an independent I
a independent self conscious existence
but only in relation others and we saw
this you know already involved in the
self consciousness section there is no
self consciousness entirely apart from
other self consciousnesses and culture
if you think about it is made up largely
of these others each of whom could be in
this disposition right so there's that
there's a reciprocity and dynamic going
on there but this is very importantly
saying that language here is what is
allowing this so he says otherwise if
there isn't the others if you're just
all by yourself if you're engaging in
what later analytic philosophers will
talk about it's a private language there
was a big discussion you know ultimately
stemming from vidcon Stein is it
possible to have a purely private
language the answer is no otherwise this
pure eye is non-existent it is not there
in every other expression it is immersed
in a reality and is a shape from which
it can withdraw itself he says it is
reflected back into itself from its
action as well as its physiognomic
expression and dissociates itself from
such an imperfect existence in which
there is always at once
too much as too little letting it remain
lifeless behind so he's contrasting
language here to our action and to what
we talked about in the physiognomies the
way in which we appear right language
has a little bit more arbitrariness to
it language is a little bit more of a
code that is independent language also
has a greater capacity for self
reference for as Hegel is putting it
here in a somewhat groping way for
having its Khan
to become its very form so Hegel is not
actually comparing language here to
action and physiognomic expression or
phrenological expression to write think
back to that section he's saying that
language is doing something a bit
different so how do we parse this out
what does he say he says language
contains it in its purity
what's the it he's going to tell us here
language alone expresses the eye the eye
itself so the eye that's being expressed
in language to who maybe back to oneself
maybe to the powers-that-be
maybe to the others and the others are
doing the same thing but in a certain
way the I never truly leaves language
language is not just a medium for
communicating the eye language is where
the eye can actually be an eye this is a
very important point a little bit more
pregnant I think than Hegel takes it as
being in his his philosophy of mind or
philosophy of spirit because he's
showing us right here that he
understands language is different than
these other what we might call more
motivated if we're using linguistic
categories more motivated forms of
expression alright so he goes on and he
says this real existence of the eye is
qua real existence and objectivity which
has in it the true nature of the eye
that's a big claim the true nature of
the eye it does not lie in mind
dissociated from language it lies in
mind connected with others through
language so he says the eye is this
particular eye but equally the universal
eye now we're going to see alienation
show up again aren't we look like in
language could get us out of a lee
edition and
we can connect everything together in a
web of language everything can be
expressed in language and yet one of the
most important functions of language the
eye or the you or the he but we might
call these Pro knowmia liders that's one
of the ways they're talked about in
linguistics this is something that was
very much the object of interest for
20th century French and German and also
certain other linguistic thinkers what
is the nature of this eye that talks
about itself that I can use it and you
can use it and it's not the same eye in
both cases but yet the eye is the same
isn't it this sounds very paradoxical
well this is where alienation takes
another form doesn't it so he goes on
and he says this is both a universal eye
and a particular eye and he says it's
manifesting is also at once the
externalization and vanishing
externalization and vanishing of this
particular eye and as a result the eye
remains in its universality so whenever
I express my own eye and I'm trying to
be this individual here you know don't
categorize me man I'm Who I am and you
know you only get to know me by spending
time with me there's there's a vanishing
to that as a matter of fact not just for
the others even for myself if I withdraw
from not just the others but the
universal eye I lose hold on my own eye
isn't that a fascinating idea what does
this have to do thinking back to what
we've been talking about Hegel's not
mentioning this here in this paragraph
but remember the noble and the base
consciousness what was the noble
consciousness doing it was identifying
its eye with the eye of the universal
order and thereby gaining some praise or
some status from the others that was a
strategy that was being pursued not just
an ethical strategy but a metaphysical
strategy
strategy about self-identity the same
thing was going on with the base
self-consciousness it was going to hold
on to its own eye and say kind of screw
the system right I'll go along with it
so so far as I have to but if I can get
something over on if I can retain
something back that's what I'm going to
do so he says the eye that utters itself
is heard or perceived and this is
interesting it is an infection in which
it has immediately passed into unity
with those for whom it is a real
existence who is that these others and
is a universal self-consciousness that
it is perceived or heard means it's real
existence dies away when I say I when I
point out myself you are seeing
something here but you I'm losing hold
on that and so are you and we're
eventually just perceiving this and you
are the others for me I am the other for
you so he goes down he says this other
nurse has been taken back into itself
and it's real existence is just this and
now notice we're going back to the
categories way at the beginning of sense
certainty right that as a self conscious
now as a real existence it is not a real
existence and through this vanishing it
is a real existence we see the dialectic
of the here and now being played out
once again language had come up at that
point in Hegel's phenomenology so very
clearly we've got something going on
here that mimics what was taking place
back then only we're doing it at a much
higher level we've built up a lot more
conceptual apparatus so we're not just
bewildered and then have to move on to
you know things and their properties we
can launch back into it and Hegel is
gonna go on and bring this to to a end
by saying this vanishing is thus itself
at once its abiding is its own knowing
of itself and it's knowing itself as
itself that has passed over into another
self that has been perceived and is
universal what is he talking about there
at the end of this passage he's talking
about realizing that we can never be
truly what we think we want to be as at
the
agents entirely on our own disconnected
from the ethical order disconnected from
the others because we never do
disconnect from them entirely every not
just action but everything that we say
about our actions everything that we do
performative Lee is you might say up for
grabs and it's only by somehow coming to
terms with that that we're going to be
able to make progress this may not be a
possibility for some people they may
have boxed themselves into a corner
where they cannot grasp what it is that
language is permitting and requiring
here if we want to use some you know
strange language a little bit here so
what are we left with again we don't get
a full theory of language here so you
know we shouldn't try to read all of
that into Hegel but we are getting is
some very interesting reflections on the
role that language does play in allowing
there to be an i in the first place in
the relation between itself and other in
the relationship between individual and
universal all of this comprised within
the ethical order
you